t mayúscula de t minúscula denota la
temperatura de mayúscula en windhoek
namibia medida en grados celsius cuando
te minúscula es el número de horas
después de medianoche en cierto día la
siguiente tabla muestra algunos valores
de la función el tiempo en horas seis
horas nueve horas y 13 horas que esto es
igual a la 1 pm y aquí abajo tengo la
temperatura 19 grados celsius 25 grados
celsius y 31 grados celsius cuando
incrementa más rápidamente la
temperatura entre 6 am y 9 m nuestra
primera opción o entre 9 m y una pm
la segunda opción o la temperatura
incrementa igual en ambos intervalos
bueno si queremos calcular la tasa de
aumento de la temperatura o tasa de
cambio tasa de cambio de temperatura
temperatura va a ser igual a nuestro
cambio en la temperatura delta de
nuestra t mayúscula sobre nuestro cambio
en el tiempo del tate minúscula este
triángulo es la letra griega delta y
representa el cambio en algo tenemos
nuestro cambio de temperatura entre
nuestro cambio en el tiempo vamos a ver
cómo se comporta esto con nuestros
valores en la tabla
nuestra opción entre 6 y 9 m tiene su
cambio de temperatura entre el cambio en
el tiempo igual a cuál es el cambio en
la temperatura
aquí aumento 6 grados celsius lo
escribimos 6 grados celsius
y cuál es nuestro cambio en el tiempo
bueno nuestro tiempo aumentó tres horas
tenemos nuestro cambio en temperatura de
6 grados celsius / un cambio en el
tiempo de tres horas
en tres horas la temperatura aumenta 6
grados o podemos decir que la tasa
promedio de cambio es 6 / 32 grados
celsius por hora noten que conservamos
igual las unidades grados celsius por
hora esta es la tasa de cambio entre las
6 am y las 9 am ahora hagamos lo mismo
para la siguiente opción entre 9 m y 1
pm nuestro cambio de temperatura entre
el cambio en el tiempo es igual a
nuestro cambio en temperatura de 25 a 31
grados celsius
así que aumenta 6 grados celsius pero
nuestro cambio en el tiempo no es de 3
horas sino de 4 horas pues pasamos de 9
horas a 13 horas
son 6 grados celsius entre 4 horas y no
tenemos que hacer los cálculos para
darnos cuenta de que aquí tenemos el
mismo cambio de temperatura pero este
cambio ocurre durante más horas así que
la tasa de cambio es menor pues nos toma
cuatro horas para aumentar 6 grados en
temperatura mientras que aquí arriba nos
tomó sólo tres horas para aumentar los
mismos 6 grados por lo que la primera
opción es la correcta
comparado con aumentar 6 grados en 4
horas pero para que la comparación quede
más clara vamos a hacer los cálculos 6
entre 4 nos da 1.5 grados celsius por
hora
y aquí podemos hacer la comparación
directa dos grados celsius por hora es
más rápido que 1.5 grados celsius por
hora y es por eso que elegimos esta
primera opción